en 2009 la france découvre et vincent
lacoste dans les beaux gosses en ado
boutonneux et pas franchement de l'amour
en moins de dix ans l'acteur s'est
installé comme une valeur sûre du cinéma
français et même du box office comme en
témoigne le million de spectateurs de
première année de thomas lilti entre
films d'auteur et film de potes qui est
vraiment vincent lacoste portrait d'un
acteur surdoué signé jérôme becker
vincent lacoste
ils commencent toutes ses phrases par
non mais surtout non mais déjà avoir
fait non mais il prend soin de ses potes
est-ce qu'on paye ses tournées wii wii
pc tourne et la cantine du collège a
changé sa vie c'est là où on m'a donné
un papier pour passer un casting pour
les beaux gosses rice aussi souple
vincent lacoste depuis que riad sattouf
l'a révélé en 2009 dans les beaux gosses
en dix ans il est devenu le petit
chouchou du ciné français avec vincent
ben c'est confortable c'est formidable
j'adore vincent s'est amusé de la dombes
et un truc étrange en fait un peu un peu
magique touchés pourquoi parce que
derrière son naturel hyper tête en l'air
se cache une vraie bête de travail
aussi à l'aise dans la comédie que le
blockbuster
sans oublier le film d'auteur j'ai peur
du regard des autres je comprends pas
quand je plains le résultat trois
nominations aux césar le prix jack your
du mec le plus stylé en 2015
je me suis toujours considéré comme ce
qu'il est mais je ne pensais pas que
il y avait d'autres personnes qui
étaient dans ce cas là aussi est
aujourd'hui vincent à 25 ans et avec 23
films en dix ans il a tellement squatter
l'écran qu'on a l'impression d'avoir
tout traversé ensemble
n'exagérons rien si si d'ailleurs cette
semaine c'est encore le cas avec un
mandat le premier film français post
attentats du 13 novembre
je m'étais jamais imaginé que je devrais
m'occuper de ma nièce un jour l'occasion
pour chicza de revenir avec lui sur ses
premières fois et d'aller traîner dans
ces bars rencontrer ses potes et ses
mentors
portrait d'un acteur qui semble vouloir
incarner l'époque pour vincent lacoste
tout commence avec une première galoche
et oui un long baiser entre deux boutons
d'acné sur le tournage des beaux gosses
en 2009
il est alors en plein brevets à 14 ans
c'était la scène du bus dans les beaux
gosses vrai c'est au cinéma en fait
et dans la vraie vie après c'était la
fête de l'humanitaire devant deep purple
c'est une autre ambiance un baiser qui
va le propulser à cannes pour la
quinzaine des réalisateurs
mais qui met surtout riad sattouf sur sa
route je veux pas de pot metge pas de
petites lolitas aux chances du cheveu
que des est vrai de vrai j'ai choisi ces
magnifiques spécimens regarde c'est un
mentor total c'est comme un grand frère
quoi sert que sans lui je n'aurais
jamais fait signer la paix le film fait
presque un million d'entrées vincent
remporté la même année le prix lumière
sa carrière est lancée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et quelques comédies plus tard dont le
astérix de laurent tirard pendant lequel
il révise ton bac tu fasses ravissement
du retrait les sectes que les textes de
quoi pendant l'été les acteurs c'est
hyper court j'ai tout le livre de
vincent devient interne dans hippocrate
de thomas lilti en 2014
c'est son premier job à l'écran et c'est
également son premier rôle dramatique
mais de confier un rôle beaucoup plus
âgée que que l'âge qu'il avait au moment
où il a interprété rila et oublié de se
vieillir dans sa façon de voir le monde
de se projeter ayant un vrai travail
étant un jeune médecin etc
il est si singulier qui va qui va
ramener tous les personnages à lui
finalement et qui va pouvoir rendre tous
les personnages crédibles peut tout
interpréter en tout cas pour moi il faut
tout interpréter la médecine c'est à
nouveau sur ce thème que lacoste et
lille s'il se retrouve en 2018 avec
première année plus d'un million
d'entrées j'étais devant le doyen de
cette manière même si ma mère était
morte
nogent du concours répétées des
sous-hommes désormais vincent n'a plus
besoin des autres pour être bankable est
thomas lilti rejoint julie delpy et riad
sattouf dans le cercle très fermé des
réalisateurs à qui l'acteur a fait
confiance deux fois en fait moi mon but
c'est de faire des films qui me plairont
aux spectateurs et en tant que
spectateur je voir les films selon les
réalisateurs mba un réalisateur qui
m'attache à les voir tous ces films et
j'ai pas envie de me cantonner qu'un
seul univers et mais par contre quand un
univers me plaît j'ai envie de le suivre
et de faire le maximum de choses avec
ces personnes en 2016
vincent gagne en puissance et après une
cure de raisin avec depardieu et
poelvoorde dans saint-amour il fait des
bisous et pour la première fois un peu
plus à virginie efira dans victoria
n'était pas vraiment ma première scène
d'amour parce que fin j'avais fait des
scènes d'amour un peu comique alors
majoritairement des scènes de branlette
ou alors des scènes vraiment
d'éjaculation extrêmement précoce ou les
choses comme ça quoi bon on était tous
assez stressé parce que virginie c'était
un peu sa première scène aussi comme ça
et justine trier l'animatrice aussi je
sentais que les corps étaient pas du
tout détendue que ça n'allait pas
virginie m'a dit alors puisque tu sais
ce que tu veux tu vas nous de mi mai
je me suis retrouvé à califourchon avec
une personne à qui je travaille au
niveau du jeu d'acteur c'était
surréaliste il était 8h dumas ça n'est
pas du tout moi j'étais tout rouge quand
ça n'allait pas quoi et j'ai commencé à
parler avec eux alors dire des trucs su
absurde du genre les chenils sein pour
lui faciliter cité c'était c'était très
précis je pense que ça les détend des
vraiment vincent découvre alors un
nouveau rapport au corps qu'il a
continué d'explorer deux ans après avec
son premier rôle gay d'emplaires aimé et
courir vite de christophe honoré tac
[Musique]
après ils auraient pu me proposer
n'importe quoi j'aurais fait quand même
il avait voulu que j'incarne un comment
dire un personnage pas corrézien mais
dans le sens même physiquement un
personnage assez des différents de moi
dans la vie quoi avec les cheveux
plaqués espèce de look un peu machin
c'est vrai c'est assez marrant à faire
c'était génial et aujourd'hui avec
amanda vincent lacoste assumer la tâche
délicate d'incarner pour la première
fois au cinéma le paris post attentats
du 13 novembre
[Musique]
c'est pas ce qu'on va devenir tous les
9,6 tellement peur là je sais ça qui est
chouette avec le film je trouve c'est
que ça fait écho à ça après c'est pas le
film c'est pas sur le bataclan quoi star
c'est un attentat qui n'existe pas pour
que ça fasse écho à ça et pour parler
ensuite d'une histoire beaucoup plus
intime de ce à quoi une nouvelle
proposition pour vincent qui sont de la
question du deuil de la paternité
lorsqu'il prend en charge sa nièce dont
la mère vient d'être tué pour porter ce
film là évidemment qui parle de quelque
chose de tragique qui est très dense il
fallait quelqu'un qui est une grâce une
luminosité une légèreté voilà vincent
c'est quelqu'un de très très profond
il est à la fois très beau mais pas
d'une manière ordinaire il est très
gracieux mais voilà un peu gauche aussi
et je pense que ça suscite une capacité
d'empathie folle quoi étaient
outrageantes stones aux amis et voilà en
fait j'ai entendu des coups de feu des
trucs j'ai couru en chantre chez moi ce
bar à deux pas du bataclan c'est son qg
où il est tout le temps fourré avec ses
meilleurs potes félix moati william leng
il est le réalisateur antoine de bari
une bande en émulation permanente qui
partagent aussi bien les demies que les
castings vincent nivelle par le haut
parce que parce que c'est quelqu'un de
sérieux avec tout ce qui concerne le
travail et les scénarios et tout ça est
du coup en fait on se parle souvent au
téléphone pays ce qui rit sont courts
métrages d'adapter avec tous les désirs
de faire du ciné depuis du cinéma depuis
toujours et obtient des caisses contre
je te la fais tout ce que l'europe c'est
toujours c'est toujours encourageant ça
c'est motivant fait et donc après deux
courts métrages pour la première fois ce
sont tour à tour félix moati est en
pointe de bari qui en feront le héros de
leur premier film
est-ce que ça serait pas un peu votre
muse si c'est vrai que vincent fait un
peu office de mu
quand j'avais proposé le le sérieux de
mon court métrage à vincent philippe et
enfin au jt en stress il ya un truc de
pression justement ne pas vouloir
décevoir
amicalement et professionnellement qui
est assez présente
mais est ce que tu m'as dit je t'aime
une fois dans la vie tu m'as jamais dit
je t'aime tu as du mal à tenir et si
mais c'est quoi ce ssl procès moi je
pense que j'étais nu et a fait qu'il
faut sans rien dit maurizio dit moi je
t'aime je t'aime je t'aime je trouve que
leur vision est intéressante et leur
univers intéressant sinon je le ferai
pas quoi il fait franchement c'est pas
uniquement parce que c'est mes amis
parce que sinon ça n'a pas vraiment
d'intérêt c'est un peu de lens reçoit
quoi c'est vraiment parce que parce que
je trouve qu'ils ont des choses à
raconter que et que je trouve que leurs
scénarios sont sont très bien voilà
à 25 ans vincent lacoste a encore
beaucoup de première fois devant lui et
en 2019 pourquoi pas la première fois
avec un césar
[Musique]